Hey guys,
so I haven't done a lot of collaborations
in my whole Youtube career,
so today is a very exciting day!
Ahh!
If you remember, a while ago I asked you
to send me an insult, a feeling, an adjective
et cetera,
so that we could make this collaboration happen.
So Skype actually brought this all together,
thank you Skype.
Brizzy voices; does the VOs,
BananaJamana does the animation,
I do the narration, and you provided the words
So thank you, thank you
Now, enjoy
this harrowing tale of middle school torment.
When I was in middle school, I lived in constant fear
of a girl named *gunshot*
one standout moment of torment was when
she made fun of me for singing out loud in class.
*scoffs*
A moment that made me scared to sing in public
for years to come.
Let me just say that calling her a bully
would be the understatement of the century.
To me, she seemed more like the spawn of zombie cats.
*Zombie cat noises*
You know, she was little in size,
but she was always pushing me around
with her superhuman strength,
calling me an island toad.
It got to the point where, rather than
risk bumping into her and her little gang, that would
hang out near the trash bin everyone smokes at,
I would eat my lunch in the bathroom
and stay there 'til class.
Fear of her pretty much ruled my world
when I was in middle school.
But all that changed one day.
I was hiding behind corn
while avoiding her and her friends
There was something different about her though.
She didn't look as scary and as confident
and evil as she usually did.
In fact, she kind of looked a little...scared, herself?
And when she got into the DeLorean her father was
driving, it all started making sense.
"Hey, how was school?" said her dad.
- "It was okay."
- "Did you learn anything? Anything at all?"
- "Uh, I mean, yeah..."
- "Oh what, like how smart you aren't?"
I couldn't believe it.
I felt both smug and sad for her at the same time.
My family was amazing, interesting, supportive.
I never realised that a parent
could be so cruel to their own kid.
After that I paid no attention to Angela's insults.
Whenever she called me an incompetent buffoon,
I would just smile at her and quietly send her love.
'Cause I knew she wasn't really being mean to me,
she was just following her father's unfortunate example,
and taking back some of the power
he took from her on a daily basis.
So wherever you are, I hope that you're happy,
and I don't mean that sarcastically either;
I really, truly, hope that you are happy,
and that you proved your dad wrong.
Just like I proved you wrong.
Oh yeah, 'cause I've been taking singing lessons,
and I discovered that my voice is actually pretty great.
Boom!
Don't forget to check out Brizzy's and Jamie's videos
and thanks again Skype for introducing me
to these super talented, awesome women.
I didn't know they existed!
*whispers* And now they're my friends.
Now they're my friends...
I'm Anna Akana, but you're not Gotham.
Your video didn't freeze.